فيما يواجه العراق تهديدات امنيه كبيره
على حدوده هناك في الداخل ما يؤرقه الفساد
اغنى دول النفطيه في العالم نعم لكنها من
اكثر الدول فسدا وهكذا ذات العراق دوله
تحتل المرتبه 157 من بين 280 على مؤشر
منظمه الشفافيه العالميه للتدليل حجم
الاختلاف في العراق يبلغ اثنين فاصله
ثمانيه في المئه من الميزانيه الدوله لعام
2021 ولا ادله على هذا الحجم من تبخر
مليار دولار من مصلحه الضرائب خبر ليس
جديدا نعم انما الجديد هو تفاصيله تتكشف
اي يوما بعد اخره تقريرا جديد للمدقيقين
حصلت عليه السوشيات بريس سرقه مدبره من
شبكه واسعه من المسؤولين وموظفي الخدمه
المدنيه ورجال الاعمال لهم علاقه بفصائل
السياسيه قويه
القصه ان الهيئه العامه للضرائب دفعت بشكل
احتيالي ما يعادل نحو مليارين ونصف
الملياردولار لخمس شركات لديها حسابات
بمئات مليارات من الودائع هذه الودائع
التي قدمتها الشركات تعاد اليها بمجرد خصم
الضرائب وتقديم بيانات ماليه محدثه لكن
الشركات قامت بسحب مبالغ مسفر رده عن طريق
الاحتلال دون ايداع اي شيء
بدات تدقيقا واستفسر الوزير وقتها احسان
عبد الجبار المصلحه الضرائب قالت انها
تحتفظ بالمبلغ تقريبا لكن تفتيشا جديدا
كشف ان الرصيد
الفعلي وصل الى 100 مليون دولار فقط رقم
في العموم كبير نعم لكن في هذه الحلقه
قليل وقليل جدا مقارنه مع ما تمت سرقته
وهذا ما ينقلنا للنقطه التاليه رئيس
الحكومه العراقيه محمد شياع السوداني شكل
هيئه عليان مكافحه الفساد في وصف انه
تشكيل استثنائيه ورغم ان هذه اللجنه
تحديدا انا مشابهه للجنه التي شكلها رئيس
الحكومه السابق مصطفى الكاظمي كان
السوداني بنفسه معارضا لها على كلنا
السوداني اكد عزمه على مواجهته جائه
الفساد
التي اصابت جميعا مفاصل الحياه هي اكثر
فتكا من جائتك
السبب وراء العديد من المشاكل الاقتصاديه
واضعاف هيبه الدوله
وزياده الفقر والبطاله وسوء الخدمات وعليه
فان برنامجنا يتضمن سياساته
واجراءات حازمه
ومتعدده الجوانب والمستويات
لمكافحه هذه الجايه